we are now learning shock of shocks that
uh andrew cuomo is in fact
a garbage jeep so when it comes to
coveted policy
uh andrew cuomo has obviously been
horrible
all the way through some of us were
mentioning the fact that andrew cuomo
was wildly under counting deaths
inside his own state for a long time he
had been suggesting for a long time to
daniel cuomo that not that many people
died in nursing homes and there are
reports for months that andrew cuomo was
deliberately under accounting death to
nursing homes by gaming the system what
he was saying is
if you were diagnosed with covet and you
lived in a nursing home and then you
went to a hospital and you died there
not in the nursing home he counts that
as not a death in a nursing home
what does this mean it means who's under
counting deaths in nursing homes by
about 50
we've known this for months now the
mainstream media have decided to catch
up on all of this
according to mediaite new york state
attorney general leticia james has
accused andrew cuomo and his
administration
of drastically under counting covert
related deaths to nursing homes citing a
76-page report released on tuesday new
york times reporter jessie mckinley
revealed the administration may have cut
the death rate in nursing homes by up to
50 percent remember that time when
andrew cuomo was the most honest of all
governors and ron desantis was gaining
the stats and it turns out ron desantis
has been way more transparent with the
stats than virtually anybody in american
government
and andrew cuomo's just a damned liar
who writes books for profit about how he
overcame
the coveted crisis by killing all the
old preliminary data
obtained by oag suggests that many
nursing home residents died from cove 19
in hospitals
after being transferred from their
nursing homes which is not reflected in
the department of health's published
total nursing home death data reads a
summary of the report's findings
the attorney general's office began
receiving complaints regarding coveted
related neglect
at nursing as early as march 2020.
the office has received more than 770
complaints through august 3rd
another 179 complaints through november
16th
his administration has been accused of
hiding the accurate estimate of nursing
home deaths as they only counted deaths
in the actual
homes one specific facility for example
reported 11 deaths to the health
department for example
james's survey of the same facility
found 29 unrecorded deaths noting 27
died well at the home
13 died after being transferred to a
hospital
so truly well done there andrew cuomo
just a quick flashback you're you're
trustworthy and reliable media here's
what they had to say about andrew cuomo
for literally a month he was the
greatest of all governors
i heard though that you had a crush on
our boyfriend andrew cuomo
dude i i i everyone does right i think
he's fantastic
you know cuomo he even had a 70
approval rating in in april with
republicans why
because he was leading even lifelong
republicans tell me they look at cuomo
and they're like god
there's a leader governor cuomo who has
been a leader
in calling for science-based uh
ways to fight this coronavirus the
academy says that he's being recognized
for quote his
leadership during the covid pandemic and
his masterful use of television to
inform and calm people around this world
oh goody goody gumdrops so that guy that
was the one you got you guys gave in to
emmy you said he was the best governor
in america
really well done across the board and i
trust all of you in the media
to tell me the truth about covered and
everything else because you were so
accurate on this one
i also trust anthony fauci right anthony
fauci said that governor cuomo was
amazing he did an amazing job
in new york anthony fauci said by the
way
fauci is now apparently at odds with
other members of the biden
administration
the world's greatest doctor i can't
believe it there i can't believe the
biden administration is sending out
people to contradict the world's
greatest doctor don't they know that the
world's greatest doctor is the master of
tough science don't they know this don't
they know that anthony fauci has a
monopoly on the science well here is um
a biden coveted advisor rebutting
voucher and saying that double masking
makes no sense at all actually
in terms of using the face cloth
coverings doubling them
actually we need to be very careful
about that that may actually be
counterproductive
not helpful uh we know and i'm not an
aerobiologist but
we know that in fact they may actually
impede the movement of air
in and out causing it to actually escape
and the big
crevices between the cloth and your face
that's a
bigger problem not a lesser problem than
one whoops
whoopsie doodle well anthony fauci being
contradicted again i can't believe that
the biden administration would shut him
down this way
how cruel how wrong how vile
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content